about sampling some you result of
sampling an application from laughing
and mining okay what what sample
complexity why should you care about
sample complexity how it's relevant to
what we're doing here
it comes up under a large number of
buzzword titles
data science machine learning data
mining pattern recognition and more and
more but all these basically are doing
in the high level the same thing you
know we are taking the beta running some
algorithm trying to fix a model to
predict the model and of course the
model is measured by how good it is
predicting results that come from the
same distribution of data or the same
world okay so there's all these
different areas that are doing it and
being computer scientist we usually
focus on the algorithm okay we look at
the efficiency of the algorithm and we
ask whether the algorithm is correct
with respect to the input and so forth
and in the context of data we even where
we of all the more practical people even
they came up with this phrase you know
this is the best the algorithm can do
with respect to the data that's
something you hear a lot in particle AI
but that's kind of dumb way to look at
it because a you know we we all knew
that you know this we held you know for
many years garbage in garbage out well
you know whoever you know good algorithm
you have if you don't give it the data
then you won't get the result okay so
what we were to look here is not so much
with them but when actually when do we
actually have enough data in order to
find the information we are looking for
so if I want a model for something at
what point the data has enough
information in order to create the model
or in order to fix and well they know
approximate the correct model so we're
not going to talk about I go to
complexity here but we go to ask a
question this is someone to toggle which
is what is it actually worth while an
algorithm at all when to actually have
data enough data in order to get a
result
okay so sample complexity try to address
these fundamental questions and in fact
the three questions are in fact
equivalent so different ways to ask the
same thing so when does the data or the
training set contain sufficient
information to make valid prediction or
to fix a sufficiently good model is the
sample sufficiently large the training
set sufficiently large we use sample and
training set here interchangeably how
accurate is the prediction that I can
infer from a sample of a given size okay
that's another way just be another way
to ask the same question now interesting
a statistic so you think that you know
all this would have been solved here we
go you almost essentially going by
statistician but a as we'll see the kind
of questions even if you phrase him in a
pure statistical modeling the kind of
question that you ask in learning are
different than the standard question
that I answered a statistics okay I just
saw the phrase here and I wouldn't get
back to this
you can look or the complication in
learning is something that statistician
called a multi comparison problem and
they have their own ways to look at it
which is I will not talk about it here
but in a way as you see the complexity
is we are asking many questions in
parallel and we want to answer them all
of them quickly simultaneously on one
set of data and
very different than you standard
statistics that you learn when you ask
one particular question okay so what I'm
going to do here so I don't have much
time to really cover every everything
that's listed here so I'll kind of a
emphasize only things that a kind of
more general and relatively different
than what you'll study in you you know
standard machine learning course but we
have to start with the whole thing of
course started with in the 70s by the VC
people and so the motivation is learning
binary classification and the
distinction between the realizable
non-eligible case so I'll talk a little
bit about it just to you know have a
concrete setting and then from that
we'll get to this general a general idea
of uniform convergence that is you know
underline everything we are doing here
now all this of course started with the
vc paper and the VC dimension is the
first concrete method to prove uniform
convergence you know I realize that
that's not the way we usually teach it
in machine learning courses so we'll
talk a little bit what we see the match
and I kind of assume that if you see to
you you probably know something about we
see dimension I'll you know I'll skip a
lot of the technicalities or we can get
to a other stuff a but you know we'll
talk a little bit about this and again
I'm going to emphasize something that is
slightly different than what we do in
standard a par clearly okay and then
I'll talk about some applications of VC
dimension then we'll go to a theory that
is somewhat newer so VC dimension is
from the 70s is something that came up
in the last 10-15 years in fact there is
a guy here in Berkeley but let that is a
major player in this complexity business
so we'll talk a little bit about how
complexity will see what it is we'll see
why it's different than VC dimension why
it's promising better title results and
then I'll show you know only very
high-level discussion of some
application or
Adam huh complexity okay all this
hopefully we'll see how much we can fit
into the time hey what's the take-home
message so obviously you know all this
uniform core values one of the most
beautiful two is that we have in
probability in computer science that was
something idea all this so I hope that
you get the idea if you haven't seen it
before that this is a really a beautiful
TV and it really started as a TV the
idea originally was just to show that
they are concept that can and cannot be
learned by a finite sample so it's like
very to ethical thing but what I'll try
to convey you in these two hours is that
it's not just theory and so a lot of
work that was done by a computer
scientist also in other areas we
actually now can get bounds concrete
bounds that are compatible with anything
else that we can do and can actually to
given practical solution so I try to
convince you know too many details that
this is more than just a theory it's
actually something that you can apply
you can actually get you know real
results out of this and the last thing
is well we usually associate
vc-dimensional Adam how is learning but
actually it's much more than learning
I'll show example a phone people call
data mining or data analysis and of
course they're also application now in a
privacy and security so it's kind of the
obvious compliment if I need this number
of sample in order to learn subject then
if I don't have that many sample then
maybe I cannot learn it complication of
course is in what I want to learn is a
usually not what I want to hide and so
there is you know very interesting
theory and all that I will not talk
about it but anyway I just want to
emphasize that all this is far beyond
this binary classification that was the
origin for this
okay so so here's a the standard a
binary classification problem so we have
so we have some unknown probability
distribution over some domain and there
is an unknown classification that
partition the domain into say the in and
out sets okay
so a concept class now we of course want
to learn a you know so we get some
example with training sets which are
example from that distribution held and
their classification and we want to be
able to predict for a new element that
come from the same distribution to
predict their classification if this was
the problem then it's almost hopeless we
won't get to this here so together with
this we get a concept class which is
basically a collection of all possible
classification that will take into
consideration okay so say we only look
at you know hyperplane that partition
the domain or we only look at
polynomials or partition or you know we
have some set might be huge might be in
finite set of concepts and we only
choose between this set of concepts in
our learning so the goal if one way to
define it is that with probability 1
minus Delta we come up there learning
generate a classification and that
classification is correct
with some Abel Absalon and now what is
correct so we find a concept or a
partition among all the possible concept
all possible partition that are given to
us that is up to Epsilon from the
optimal and when we take and this is the
expected arrow and the expectation is
taking over the distribution of the
input ok so that's the standard binary
classification I'm sure that you saw it
before okay so in picture what we have
is we have the red and blue points that
in and out we get all sorts of possible
classification to choose more
we want to choose a classification that
fits as much as possible they the truth
we'll skip one and how do we know the
truth so we get these samples and so if
the sample here says that this is out
there that would not definitely would
not choose choose this one as the inset
and you know this one says it's in then
everything that include this can still
be one of the classic in classification
okay so a it's a important for us to
distinguish between two cases and this
would lead to the different definition
of converges even from converges so in
the realizable case we someone tell us
that there is a concept in our concept
class that is perfect that is consistent
with all our training set okay so in the
realizable case there is a concept in
the set of concept class that is
consistent with all our training set we
might it might be very hard to find it
might be exponentially r-25 but there is
such a thing well so how what does we
what do we need from the sample in the
realizable case okay so how do we you
know how good sample we need in order to
find a solution or a concept that is
very close to the optimal well so the
trick of course is we look at for every
concept so let's a
okay so let's see we the the perfect
concept I notice it's a SHINee let's see
CB the different the optimal concept
let's Delta of CH be all the elements in
the domain which I don't see all of them
in which they differ okay so if I pick a
sample in this set then I will know that
age is not the Kuwait concept because it
Edgewood my age would not classify it
correctly as it says in the training set
okay so what do I need in order to find
a good classification well I need to
have a sample that hits every set of
these deltas when you go over all the
deltas for all the possible concept for
each of this set that has probability
greater than Epsilon I want a sample to
hit such a set okay so in other way it
for every concept that differ from the
optimal concept by measure Epsilon
I want the sample to hit I want to
sample to hit the difference between
them so in other word what I need and in
that case well I really the probability
that I make an arrow if I choose this
one that if I choose this one then there
was no example in which then if I chose
this one that means that there was no
sample there was no software that showed
me that this one is wrong and therefore
it has to be a quake up to it all
bounded by Epsilon
okay now what's important here for what
we continue what we did data is that
what we need what we need of the sample
is to intersect every set among all the
possible delta set that is not too small
so usually we say well how many
something I need in order to heat a set
once but now I have a huge collection of
sets
possibly infinite collection of sets and
I need my sample simultaneously to heat
each of these sets at least once okay
now the more reasonable a model of
learning is the unintelligible case in
which we are not guaranteed that our
training set is consistent with any of
the concept that we know there are two
reason for that first of all why would
you know a concept set that includes the
tools you know who gave you that
information but yeah yeah okay yeah okay
and and and the other one is the arrow
okay if you get real data that you have
noise okay so yeah if all the noise is
guaranteed to be below Epsilon well you
don't okay but if you have at least one
element and any of you who work with
petitioner there are always some
elements that are outliers if you have
one element out of that then it doesn't
it's not consistent with this okay so
what are you doing the unrealizable case
well then you said well okay so for each
concept I kind of look at the empirical
evidence eped on my training set okay
and I want to choose the one that
minimizes this empirically hole okay and
so now we have that if our sample
estimate correctly or estimate within
epsilon arrow all the event delta c age
then we have enough information in order
to find a concept such that it's arrow
with respect to the optimal is no more
than a then well actually have to have a
have to estimate each of them with
epsilon over two in order to get a
website although if I estimate all the
differences by epsilon then I get
something that the concept is
a quaked up to arrow or is the concept
is no worse than the optimal plus 2
epsilon navel again beyond the details
what I want you to get out of this is
that what we need is again we need a
sample and now it's not enough that it
hit every set at least once we have a
collection of sets again it might be in
finite collection of sets it's the
difference between all hypotheses and
the correct hypothesis and we want our
sample to estimate within epsilon arrow
the size of all this set uniformly ok so
we need the sample that simultaneously
estimate the probabilities or the ratio
of the sample that fall into this set is
proportional to the probability of these
sets up to an epsilon arrow yes that was
the that was the realizable case now we
have the unrealizable case there might
not be a concept that actually agree
with our training set hopefully there's
a concept that so in fact there might be
no concept that agree even on most of
the training set we still just want to
find the best concept that we have among
all the concepts that are available to
us ok ok so this wing us now to the
definition of the uniform convergence
come from the BC paper long before we
knew about machine learning this is in
the 70s ok
so assume that we have a set of function
we say that the set of function and this
again can be infinite set of function
finite we say that the function has the
uniform convergence property with
respect to a domain Z if there is a
function that is a function of the well
if there is function M that is a
function of the family of function or
concept
epsilon Delta such that this function
for every epsilon Delta is finite and
this is going to be the size of our
sample and such that for any
distribution D and that's the pole pole
here the ever distribution D on our
domain and any sample Z 1 to Z M well
this is the M okay if we have this
sample then with probability 1 over
Delta our sample estimate so these are
empirical estimate of the expectation of
F this is the actual expectation of F ok
now we look at the maximum overall or
the soup overall the function and we
want this to be bounded by Epsilon
now before we talked about expectation
we talked before we talk about
probabilities now we talk about
expectation of function so obviously if
I can expect if I can estimate the
expectation of function I can have the
characteristic function of each event
and it spits expectation is the
probability of that event so I'm
actually just a generalizing the
previous requirement so again what I
have now is I have a set of function
might be in finite and I want the
property that for any epsilon Delta
there is a finite value M such that if I
take a sample of M if I take a sample of
M items from that distribution and I
look at the empirical expectation of
each function you know the the
difference between this and the actual
expectation of the function in that
distribution the soup overall the
function is bounded by epsilon with
probability 1 minus epsilon ok and this
I want for any distribution D
why this is what I want full earning so
think about F is the loss function okay
so a loss function even if you don't
know it's the penalty you have for
making the wrong decision so in the
simple binary case the it's one penalty
if you have the wrong answer and zero
penalty if you the right answer but it
can be you know any function and often
you use different functions so if f of H
is now the collection of all the
families of a penalty with respect to
all the hypotheses okay now if F H has
the uniform convergence property that
means that I can take a finite sample
and I can take day and I can run at
least conceptually we don't talk about
the complexity of this but I am looking
at the empirical risk minimization that
means I find the concept that has the
minimum error or minimum loss among all
the arrows that I have among the all the
concept that I have and if I have you
know if this is a uniform convergence
set then I have a very good estimate for
the arrow of all the concepts okay and
if I take the minimum one then it's
actually this according to vapnik this
is actually the definition of being able
to learn a concept class okay so if I
have if I can use a finite sample in
order to identify the concept in the set
of concept that has the minimum arrow
okay and so the function M as a as a
function of the set of function f H is
the sample complexity of the problem
okay so now you know so that's basically
how for y uniform convergence
is they underline you know to ethical
property that you need in order to lien
okay or in other words you can actually
if you look at the way of uplink right
see this is kind of the definition of
learning
okay now you wonder a now all this of
course was completely well mostly ignore
until a eighty eight eighty four when a
less violent came with the park learning
idea and the park learning basically
said this in a the computer science
setting where we actually asked that the
learning will be done in polynomial time
and this led to you know which do e of
you know learning okay but in terms of
the sample complexity this is all goes
back to public work okay so okay so this
was kind of the introduction about what
is uniform convergence and now we'll
move to how do we achieve uniform
convergence
vc-dimension first example other Oaxaca
flexible data example by the way they'll
other techniques to do it but they all
in them well I'll talk about later
they're all kind of in the same setting
of the VC dimension nodal item how
complexity okay let me just put all this
in some background which might actually
clarify some point to some people so
assume that we have a you want to zero
an ACM sample from some distribution so
this is the empirical distribution
function that we take from the sample
then the strong law of large numbers
tell us that for any given X the
empirical distribution for X will
converge to the value of the
distribution at X okay so that's the
loaf large number okay
the containing of the Bangkok mentality
om is the first one that a build uniform
convergence but only for this set of
events ok so the set of events
corresponding to the probability
distribution for probability
distribution and they show that this is
has the uniform convergence for PT there
are a lot of a theorem of this form but
if you come from - from Jerusalem that's
the etske Keifer war for which the one
you know
so this basically showed that a the
uniform convergence can actually be
translated to a large deviation bound of
the form that we need but again this is
just for the set of events ok that
corresponds you you know to a
distribution so putting it in the
setting this kind of a pure mathematics
setting what the VC dimension is doing
is it I'll just say it tried to
characterize other set of events or
function that have this uniform
convergence property so this is well you
know what we are doing fits into the
general setting of mobility
oh it's N it's M sorry I'm sorry sorry
the question okay so okay so we all know
one way to get uniform covariance that's
Union bound okay so if and also if if
each if I want to be able to heat every
event of probability epsilon then you
know I can have a I can have a sample of
size that is proportional to the number
of concepts plus the arrow and obviously
you know I hit all the concepts so the
probability that I don't hit one of them
is 1 minus epsilon to them and then I
take it over all the possible concept
and I get you know bounded by Delta okay
so why Union wine bound doesn't help us
or why doesn't it so no problem well I
would love time to get into detail but I
think you all could realize that we can
easily learn a an interval with a finite
number of samples so what does mean
learning in interval so assume that we
have a distribution over sum over the
line say bounded segment between a and B
to make it easy and there is some two
classification little a little B which
is an interval on the large domain and
our concept class are all the possible
interval okay so we have infinite number
of concepts and it's not easy to it's
not hard to see that we can actually
learn the a correct concept by you know
finite sample that is just a function of
epsilon and Delta
basically the trick is that assume that
a B is the correct concept define
interval here and interval here each of
them it with measure epsilon over two
okay so if
my arrow so I so here the example that I
see is positive this other example I see
as negative my algorithm just take the
interval that include all the positive
example as the in now if there is an
arrow and again be a is the real
interval of the correct interval well if
there is a more than epsilon then there
is some interval epsilon over to here an
epsilon over to here that we missed and
in our training set and so of course a
finite training set which decides just a
function of Epsilon and it would give me
that okay so what happened here before
we needed you know a Union bound could
only work in finite number of concept
here in finite number in concept as it's
so easy to learn well so each sample
here exclude many possible interval so
if I have this negative example that I
know that all the intervals that include
this one are excluded the Union bar of
course some of over light overlapping of
vertices so we need something much
better much smarter you know that you
figure out how many samples we need okay
that's the proof okay so we switch to
so a so we talked a little bit about
vc-dimension a I'm going to skip a lot
of the proofs it's all here it's only in
the deck if someone asked me you know
I'll be happy to but we don't have time
to cover all this I want to get to new
material so just remember that for the
realizable case we needed the following
property we need that so now we think
about it in a more abstract thing we
have a collection of sets over the
universe of the domain and there is some
distribution defining over the domain
for the realizable case we needed a
property for any set R such that the
probability of our ended in is greater
than Epsilon we our sample intersect
I'll this is what we call an epsilon net
and for the unrealizable case we needed
that for any R we can absolutely
estimate or the ratio of the
intersection of our sample with our okay
well approximate the probability of our
approximate within Epsilon
we call this the epsilon sample okay now
usually because of PAC learning we
talked about epsilon net but for
application that I'll be on a you know
the machine learning we're actually
really interested in the epsilon sample
okay so I'm going to talk a lot more
about the epsilon samples also assuming
that some of you already saw the epsilon
net with us okay so but just to remind
you what the VC dimension so we
summation upside the whole thing so we
have a domain we have a set of a
collection of sets which we'll call
ranges just so we don't use sets all the
time X can be finite or infinite al can
be finite or infinite and now is just a
family of subsets and the important
thing in the VC dimension is the concept
of projection so let's fix a set s out
of the domain and now s is finite okay
so the domain can be in finite but now
we fix a finite set and now we ask if I
look at all the ranges but I restrict
them to the set s
how many different ranges we actually
have okay so I can start with a finite
number of ranges but if my set is finite
then many of the ranges when they are
projected or the finite set either
coincide or how completely not there or
suppose so I asked you know how many
sets are in the projection so now if the
projection on M element if the
projection has 2 to the M sets that
means every dichotomy or every subset is
represented in this projection when we
then we say that our shutter s and in
putting some motivation it is it means
that the projection already explained
already represent all the possible
dichotomies of the set s so okay so now
the VC dimension is basically the
maximum size s that is shuttle by hour
okay now it's not every set of that size
will be shut off hour but we're looking
at the maximum size of a set or the set
of maximum size that can be shuttle by
hour so this is the VC dimension and if
there is no assembly such limit then we
say that the VC dimension is infinite
and as I mentioned before the bid the
initial work really really was focused
on the fact that there a sets that have
a concept class that have been finite
dimension but we now really are
interested in really evaluating the VC
dimension okay I assume most of you know
about it so you know let's just take two
examples so you know if I look at
interval so this explain why we can
study interval a so easily so if I look
at intervals on the line so I definitely
I usually can a shuttle two elements so
there's an interval here that would
it told us an interval that would
include most of the enters into vada
include this one and there's an interval
it does include any of them so that I
can shatter a set of two but there's no
way I can shatter a set of three because
there's a no interval that we included
to wet point doesn't include the blue
point so interval on the line have very
low VC dimension and we see later that
the VC dimension actually give you the
size of the training set that you need
you know the terrain eight which will
explain example we saw before if you
look at you know a half space on the
planed and you can shut it every three
point there's no way you can shutter you
can distinguish between oh can separate
the two weight from the two blow so the
a the VC dimension of half plane is weak
and just that you don't get the idea
that every simple example has a small VC
dimension so if we look at all convex
bodies on the plane in fact it's enough
to look at all polytopes
then this a concept class has infinite
VC dimension Y so I can put any number
of points in a circle and I can identify
any subset of these points and I connect
them I can connect them to include them
in a polytope and you know in this
structure and not include the rest of
them okay so I can basically shatter any
set of points for any size using convex
bodies and so they this concept class
has infinite VC dimension okay
so a the important application now is
that if you tell me the PC dimension I
can tell you how many samples I need in
order to estimate the probability within
epsilon a everything an epsilon arrow of
all the ranges in a range space okay
again this is the epsilon a sample QM
there is a similar tiem with the square
here is eliminated for the absolute for
the epsilon net but a for a application
we need later this is actually the more
important theorem this is what allows
you to use this for other data mining or
other data analysis problems okay so the
most important thing to notice is that
the size of the sample is a function of
D epsilon and Delta but it's not a
function of the size of X and it's not a
function of the size of our okay so
although I am estimating simultaneously
they pull the probabilities of infinite
number of ranges or sets okay the number
the size of the sample I need is only a
function of the VC dimension and they
all it's not a function of the number of
events or the number of sets that I'm
estimating okay this is by the way not
the title result you can get you can get
a slightly better result using something
called chaining but I really want to
spend two minutes on this beautiful
theorem so that's maybe the only proof I
want to go through so this is one of the
most a beautiful and tricky proof this
is the double sampling idea oh sorry so
before we
before moving the steel room there is
this technical result which I won't
prove you because the poof itself is
just by induction but it's this is
actually well the real value of this
intervention come form it's known as the
Sauer lemma but for those who come from
Jerusalem is the South shellack lemma
and I mention it in case someone from
the other logic program is here to show
that all this is actually related to
logic as well okay so if we have the
range space of dimension D and if we
take a subset s of size M then we ask
well ok what's the size of the
projection of range set on that sample
so we know that if the VC dimension is D
then the projection of D elements is 2
to the D I mean that's how we define it
VC dimension ok we said there is a set D
so that it such that the projection on D
has 2 to the D sets ok but the important
thing of the so lemma is that as we go
beyond D the size of the projection
grows not exponential
but polynomial so it goes polynomial in
D they so this is the crucial way we're
using the VC dimension up to do you know
if we have D element and the projection
is 2 to the D and if we get a larger set
of element than the projection on that
set has only M to the D different sets
and jumping ahead to the punchline of
the tiem what does it says is that if
you look at the sample the sample has
only to deal with not with all the
possible ranges in the world or in the
range space but only with this number of
ranges because on the sample these are
the size of the projection the bound on
the size
protection okay so I have what five
minutes okay
okay so when I teach it it takes a whole
hour so but I really the idea here is
just to show you the the cleverness of
this technique and most people the first
time you see it you don't really get you
know okay so how do we prove the epsilon
sample so here's the event that we want
to bound okay so we choose a sample of
size M and we want to bound the
probability that there is a set an R
that is not well approximated by our
sample we want to show that this is
bounded by Delta so now we choose
another sample Moakley Y and now I want
to estimate salt more complicated event
so we don't know how to estimate there
this one so we define them even more
complicated event and we try to estimate
it so now we want to estimate the
probability that well the first sample
was bad but the good sample is good okay
what is meaning good well for that some
for that set for which a photo said that
for which the first sample failed to
estimate them quickly the other sample
estimate them properly okay so remember
that the these fractions the probability
of Val you know is peafowl so you know
this function supposed to be closer to P
alpha okay so now obviously the
probability of this e 2 is smaller than
probability of e 1 because it has
another restriction but this restriction
is kind of trivial because that's what
we expect okay from a sample to have so
a well formulate it by showing that the
probability of e 2 okay is the
probability of not satisfying e2 is so P
2 is just is that okay that the
probability of e 1 is bounded by twice
the probability of e 2 okay so the
probability of e 2 is not that much
smaller okay so the baby remember again
e 2 is smaller but it's not that smaller
okay is no more than twice
okay so I'll skip the Italian but you
know so how do we prove this ratio well
we look at the ratio between this
probability that's basically the
probability of e to condition only one
well what's the probability of e to the
condition only one was the probated that
they least said that you know was not
estimated well by the first sample but
it is estimated well by the second
sample
well the probabilities exist such a set
well it's definitely greater than the
probability that an arbitrary one
arbitrary set will have this property
and again since this is what we expect
from the sample this is high probability
ability at least half so we are done so
we get this ratio okay so now we we
define celled event which is kind of
simplification of e 2 so it's e 2 prime
so remember here we say the first sample
miss the write probability by more than
epsilon the second sample is within
epsilon over 2 of the right sample so if
so now we want that there is there is
any set R such that the difference
between its intersection of n with n n
its intersection with T is greater than
epsilon 2 m okay so remember this one is
the intersection greater than epsilon n
this is smaller than epsilon n over 2 so
the difference has to be this so this
one a is more general than that one okay
and this is powerful for that
so now we want to show that now we are
we getting to the punchline okay so we
want to show that we can actually bound
the probability of this event so now we
said well we had one sample and then
another sample and what's up well we put
some property that is sample data but
they're both samples so we could as well
just take one sample of two M elements
and partition them to two samples okay
now I can partition them any way I want
as long as I don't look at their values
so it's going to be easier to do the
following partition so assume that I
take Z and it has two m elements now for
each pair Z 1 Z 2 Z 3 3 4 and so forth
with probability 1/2 we add either
switch their audio note or with
probability 1/2 the first one go to M
and the second one goes to T or with
probability 1/2 the first one go to T
and the second one go to n so basically
I partition the Z into two sets by
taking any successive two and randomly
assign one of them to any one event to
three why we do it you'll see in a
second it fits into a jello box ok so
now we get to the punchline so now we
look for one particular set and we ask
what the probability that we get this
property that our intersection of n is
much bigger than our intersection of T
ok if I have this probability then the
union of this is the event that I want
but now what happened now we have a set
of elements and we partition them
randomly to two subsets and we ask
whether one subset intersection is has
large intersection without the other one
has small intersection of so far all the
opposite ok the event now has nothing to
do with the original set Z I could
choose any set of element you know out
of my domain the probability now is only
the partition of the 2m elements into
two sets of M okay so again I have a set
of two M elements and I asked what
happened what's the probability that
when I partitioned these two M into two
sets of M one of them has large
intersection with Al and that one has
small intersection without this for
ability has nothing to do with the way I
chose Z I can have worst case Z orbital
is e the only thing now is a probability
on the partition okay so I got rid of
all the setting of all the range space
setting I'm just asking a question about
the particular set Z okay okay so now
basically whatever plus my plus one
minus one in the partition in the
splitting so now I look at the pail I do
most of them all in all it doesn't
matter how I assigned them either both
of them are no T now and again it
doesn't matter how do I sign them or one
of them is in how one of them is not
enough and so this probability 1/2 half
that I put this in the in n Ont okay so
now this what's written here is
basically a sum of plus 1 minus 1
independent and viable whose probability
1/2 1/2 and we know how to bound it
using a channel bomb so for a particular
set the probability that I have this
property that I splitted in such a way
that there is many more element of our
in one of them then in the other one
okay
is just reduced to the sum of plus minus
plus minus one you know is probability
1/2 half and I have a bound for that now
this is a bound for one particular set
and now I use the Psalter lemma to say
oh but on my set Z that has two M
elements there are only two today m to
these sets that I have to consider okay
so the probability of the event a one
which was borne by twice of
ability of even I'm this bound by twice
from the two here this is the number of
elements I have in Z to the D is the
number of a sets they never of set the
not the size of the projection of our on
my sample and these are the number of
sets that can be partitioned correctly
or not and for each of them that's the
probability that it partition wrong and
now there is quite a bit of arithmetic
to show that this bounded by Delta
translate to this kind of mm will not
with you okay so that's the proof of the
epsilon sample that's the high level
proof of the epsilon sample and okay so
we'll take a break and then we get back
to this will see the application of this